bon là c'est un peu le bazar je
conviendrais mais regarder ce qui va
sûrement bien ce que mon super content
c'est alors non pas le galaxy folle n'en
parlons pas aujourd'hui c'est plutôt ça
là une très très grosse télé qu l'aide
quatre cas le hd c'est la 65 pouces 163
cm c'est un monstre ça c'est pour
regarder game of thrones et rixheim côté
la barre de son harman kardon qui paraît
vaé est juste énorme
c'est là hwr 850 on en reparle très très
très bientôt
j'ai été gâté parce que comme ils ont un
partenariat avec ocs balade pour game of
thrones eh bien j'ai eu sweat-shirt
winter is coming game of thrones process
mois gentiment envoyé aussi le petit
monopoly game of thrones valable et
justin formule 1 le petit bug quelques
petits autocollants ici bon tout ça on a
déjà testé il ya quelques jours c'est la
once attestée dans quelques jours c'est
la galaxy tab est 5e
bon on en reparle bientôt et ce en
oubliant quelques jours on va parler
d'un samsung galaxy watch active elle
est à mon poignet je traîne à tester ça
on en reparle dans quelques jours
[Musique]
mais ce matin on se concentre sur le
samsung galaxy à 40 ces deux nouveaux
modèles vous savez la gamme galaxy a
beaucoup changé
deux ans la gamme galaxy j bonjour la
gamme galaxy s est un smartphone qui
serait sorti l'année dernière sous la
gamme galaxy j je pense
si je prends pas trop me tromper le cac
40 alors à 40 qui est assez intéressant
parce qu'il vous permet d'avoir un
smartphone qui est vraiment pas cher
avec un superbe écran super amoled des
mieux c'est de le montrer le design est
pas mal quoique pas extraordinaire
regardez vous avez un d'eau en plastique
ici il ya un espèce de petit effet 3 2
bon faut vraiment aller chercher ça
c'est assez sobre assez classique pour
un peu négatif de ce doc comme ça c'est
qu'il va facilement prendre les traces
de doigts point positif de ce smartphone
c'est qu'il est vraiment hyper compact
il pèse 140 grammes vous avez un écran
qui pas très grand de 5,9 pousse ça
c'est vraiment bien pour le tenir à une
main comme ça c'est des petits formats
moi je me sens vraiment encore très
pratique alors que les smartphones
deviennent de plus en plus grands
pouvaient facilement l'utiliser à une
main ça s'est également pas très très
très positif
il n'y a pas de signe distinctif
particulier il a pas grand chose qui va
le démarquer un écran infiniti dû être
la petite goutte d'eau ici sur le côté
capteur d'empreinte digitale le branding
il si samsung double module photo bouton
de volume sur le côté bouton pour
l'allumer pour l'éteindre vous avez un
haut parleur mono qui est juste là de la
recharge en usb c'est la prise jack et
toujours conservé son côté vous avez
juste votre tiroir de cartes sim qui
hélas est sur le dessus pas grand chose
si ce n'est le micro pour la réduction
du bruit voyez c'est un smartphone qui
est assez standard qui est pas fou fou
quand on voit comme ça mais qui par
contre sa gamme de prix pour près de
truc qui va chemin bien c'est son
superbe écran super amoled
je vous disais un écran qui ne venait de
5 à 8 9 pouces 2340 par 1080 pixels qui
est vraiment vraiment agréable ça c'est
pour moi le point le plus positif je
trouve assez lumineux on pousse
luminosité à fond je le trouve vraiment
bien sauf que les couleurs sont bien les
contrastes sont bien c'est du super
amoled vraiment vraiment pratique la
première chose à faire quand vous le
prenez en main c'est de venir ici dans
les paramètres vous aller dans les
paramètres d'affichage ce que je vous
conseille d'aller dans le mode d'écran
par défaut il est en affichage adaptatif
je trouve que on va beaucoup de lumière
bleue qui reçoit sur le côté
les couleurs sont très très très vive
trop saturé je conseille vraiment de
vous mettre en cinéma à molette et là
vous étonnerai le meilleur résultat des
couleurs qui sont un peu plus pastel
plus douce et ensuite deuxième point qui
est assez important c'est d'aller
filtrer la lumière bleue vous activez
votre fils tu de lumière bleue et vous
venez cas c'est un petit peu la lumière
bleue la voyez vous le mettez à peu près
par ailleurs ne pas citer si vous le
mettez trop fort c'est horrible si vous
le mettez pas du tout c'est trop bleu
vous venez le cas c'est un petit peu par
là ça va devenir légèrement mais ça mon
avis c'est vraiment bien et pour le
repos de vos yeux pour éviter la fatigue
oculaire pour moi ça devient vraiment
indispensable autre point qui est
vraiment intéressant comme vous êtes
super amoled c'est à dire quand un pixel
et noir c'est un pixel qui est en vous
mettez en mode nuit alors vraiment
lorsque vous les dire économisez votre
batterie ce qui fait que toutes les
parties qui sont noirs ici là sont des
pixels qui sont éteintes donc ils vont
pas du tout consommer d'énergie donc là
vous avez un smartphone qui dans un mode
en gros qui n'est pas économies
d'énergie mais qui ne va pas consommer
beaucoup de batterie ça s'est vraiment
bien c'est tout l'intérêt justement
d'avoir des écrans super amoled parce
qu'avec le lcd vous ne pouvez pas le
faire
bon après y'a pas mal de petites autres
possibilités de ce que vous avez ou
annuel qu'est le nouvel os de samsung
qui marche très bien que je trouve
vraiment très sympa les obliger petite
mise à jour logicielle à faire vraiment
bien alors vous avez deux dans vos
données biométriques vous avez votre
capteur d'empreinte digitale au dos un
peu standard mais qui marche extrêmement
bien vous positionnez votre doigt sa
déverrouille immédiatement plutôt bien
vous avez aussi failli seul bloc
si vous utilisez votre caméra l'avant
moins sécurisées mais ça fonctionne
également de toute façon j'imagine pas
qu'on va et vous piquer votre smartphone
mais de votre photo en face pour les
vidéos et comme ça bon je dis pas que ça
peut pas arriver mais ça me semble quand
même assez rare
lowe s est bien toutes les questions de
bien-être numérique bourse avoir ici ou
annuelle ça marche parfaitement bien
basé sur un android 9 paille vous avez
également de la navigation par gestes
que vous pouvez activer pour faire comme
vous les voyez pas mal de petites
possibilités ou un éveil moi
personnellement j'adore maintenant y'a
un truc qui est un peu moins bien c'est
la partie audio parce que vous avez un
seul haut parleur mono là et le rendu
est pas extraordinaire
lo'jo et à ses médiums ici lorsque vous
le mettez à franco mella ça tout de
suite un petit peu a saturé
bon là c'est un peu le poids en plus de
regrets pour ce smartphone aux tambours
devant l'écran qui est bien qu'il ya
calibré autant l'audio au niveau du haut
parleur est pas à la hauteur il est
assez criard
si vous voulez profiter d'une bonne
qualité audio sur ce smartphone il faut
utiliser la prise jack que vous avez là
et mettre un casque
alors mettez un casque de bonne qualité
parce que si vous utilisez un casque pas
de bonne qualité
le rendu sera moins bien le spectre est
mieux c'est mieux c'est pas où mais
c'est mieux mais si vous voulez vraiment
profité d'une bonne qualité audio fouet
dans vos parents
vous allez dans son libre à sion vous
allez tout en bas vous allez dans
paramètres de son avancée vous allez
dans qualité et effets sonores que ça
fallait un petit peu loin et vous allez
active est ici le dolby et moss est là
tout de suite l'expérience audio aux
casses devient vraiment bonne en gros
vous passez d'un son avec un haut
parleur mono ici qui vraiment pas
terrible à un casque up a une qualité
audio qui est très bien et vous voyez
pour l'utiliser uniquement du vietnam au
casque quand vous les branches et hop ça
désactive
et c'est plus possible les performances
sont pas dingue on est sur un exil aux
7885 c'est pas un truc le plus fou on
n'a qu'à jihad ram qui vous assurera
suffisamment de fluidité pour votre
smartphone 64 giga du stockage en est
livre vous pouvez monter jusqu'à 500 12
giga grâce à une carte microsd
ce qu'on voit c'est que ce smartphone
est pas destiné à des gamers avertis
quand on est sur un stand qui coûte pas
très cher
on est sur un smartphone qui vous
servira pour les usages courants
pas plus pas moins c'est exactement la
même chose au niveau de l'autonomie vous
avez une batterie de 3100 millions
terreur qui vous accompagnera une
journée sans souci alors attention une
journée oui mais si vous n'êtes pas trop
en train de jouer sur des jeux pas trop
compliqué a pas trop lourd en termes
d'os en tout cas sur des petits jeux
mais les grandes dit mais quand je dis
ça et si vous n'êtes pas trop regarder
des vidéos sinon je veux oui ça va tout
de suite pomper davantage si par contre
vous l'utilisez mais pas trop quelques
appels quelques sms l'affût de
consultation et a+ pour gratter un peu
plus d'une journée
mais bon guère mieux celui là en tout
cas je le donne pour une journée après
un intéressant parce qu'il a une
recharge rapide 15 watts et par la
recharge la plus rapide du monde
mais vous branchez le meilleur et c'est
reparti pour un petit moment côté photo
faut pas trop lui demander la lune vous
avez un double capteur photo 16
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.0 et un 5
mégapixels grand-angle qui ouvre à f 2.2
et filmer en 1080p et l avant vous avez
une caméra de cette fille de vingt-cinq
mégapixels
je vous le donne dans le mille dès qu'il
ya beaucoup de lumière ça marche là on
est sur un capteur principal et au paf
grand-angle alors qu'ils font tous les
deux à faire je dirais quand même que le
grand temps que la qualité quand même -
terry mais sans le capteur principal
quand il ya beaucoup de lumière vous
verrez franchement vous serez absolument
pas déçu sur cette rose on a quelque
chose qui est très naturel c'est pas sûr
saturé on a du détail alors faut éviter
de 4,3 je mets dedans mais même lorsque
vous voulez venir un petit peu zone et
on perd pas trop en qualité le boulot
est assez bien fait là dessus de la part
de samsung pareil grand-angle à tout ça
johnny un peu plus les couleurs sont
moins jolie sutil beaucoup plus jeunes
avec un effet contre jour dès que vous
arrivez sur le grand voyage on a des
résultats qui sont quand même assez
sympa pour moi ça smartphone vous allez
pouvoir vous faire quelques souvenirs à
voir des photos
ceux qui sont pas mal notamment en plein
jour attention quand du mouvement si
vous allez récupérer un petit peu de
flou voyez la up
j'ai un petit peu de foot juste un petit
peu moins net que vous avez un petit peu
moins de lumière tout de suite le
résultat est beau ce moment terrible
savoure à mettre beaucoup de bruit c'est
très imprécis et la caméra de celle ci
fait boulot mais bon voilà c'est pas un
truc de dingue
de toute façon vous l'avez compris on
est sur un smartphone à 259 euros
on va pas attendre d'avoir des résultats
comme sur un smartphone qui va coûter
700 et 800 voire 900 ou a même plus
donc on a des résultats qui sont
honnêtes et vous en avez pour votre
argent ce que je pourrais regretter sur
ce smartphone c'est qu'on n'ait pas de
certification contre l'eau et la
poussière alors assurez-vous ainsi
rencontre lou un petit peu de plus ça
devrait quand même plutôt pas mal se
passer
attention si vous l'échappée dans
beaucoup d'eau dans vos toilettes
pourquoi pas dans une piscine
là ça veut dire un peu plus compliqué
néanmoins ce smartphone moi je trouve
vraiment intéressant parce que pouvoir
vous êtes à 259 euros vous avez un écran
super amoled qui parfaitement bien un
appareil photo qui fonctionnera en
conditions de bonne luminosité et en
audio il sera bien lorsque vous allez
brancher la prise casque et vous allez
activer le dogme atmos au delà de ça
laissera produits équilibrés faut
pouvoir faire quelques jeux les réseaux
sociaux je dirais qu'il s'adresse à des
personnes qui veulent pas dépenser trop
d'argent mais qu'ils veulent quand même
à barra smartphones qui est bonne
facture sans en avoir trop je sais pas
ce que vous en pensez et dites moi ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
ce qu'ils peuvent ou tenter ce
smartphone se à 40 qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la nouvelle gamme de samsung
de cette année elle vous plaît oui non
pas comment vous invite à marquer tout
ça en bas aux commentaires venant rendez
vous dès demain parce que demain vous
emmène dans des coulisses dans un truc
un peu moi je vous en dis pas plus et
surtout vraiment cool qui vous montre un
produit qui n'est pas encore sorti enfin
je vous en dis pas plus vous venez
demain vous verrez c'est top à demain
pour issa thiaw
[Musique]